[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
due to the virus I will not be running
through the audience high-fiving let's
get a guy never did that pandering
[ __ ] ever I did but I do appreciate
you being here for crying out loud I
mean there's a lot of people there's
people all over this country who are
cancelling going to shows I don't know
what to be liked up to do a show of
nobody was here we so awkward to have to
pump in the sound of liberals pretending
to be outraged at the end but to say you
know California has officially declared
a state of emergency about the corona
virus but Disneyland is still open so
pack yourself in with strangers from all
over the world and write a log
a ride literally called Splash Mountain
but don't touch your face mystic
explains their new slogan Disneyland it
will leave you breathless nothing a
little pop before the show it's all
about the big lesson for me is that
being asked not to touch your face
really makes you want to touch your
notice that I mean jesus-fucking-christ
good they get off this face thing every
day don't don't touch this don't touch
your face it's like my face me tootin my
hand got me crazy yesterday I made a
sandwich with my elbows Jesus
get a grip people the experts this week
said yeah babe not to touch your face I
said keep your hands busy
this is just what teenage boys need to
hear
what are you doing in there I'm warding
off the Corona fellow so you know it's
just panic whenever there's a threat any
kind understand this toilet paper
right first thing to sell out because
people are scared shitless you can't
even get it in stores now there's even a
new song about it by the by that band
panic at the Costco but don't worry
about it because Donald Trump MD Trump
University School of Medicine is on the
case this man is a fountain of
misinformation this week he said it's
okay for people infected with the virus
to go to work which raises the question
can you get it from pulling stuff out of
your ass is that the way you get the
virus
that's my face and also Trump said he
had a hunch he said he had a hunch that
the virus wasn't as bad as the World
Health Organisation says so on the one
side you have the World Health
Organization on the other side you have
a guy who stared at an eclipse
but I tell you politics whoa right the
difference a week makes we were here we
were here one week ago there was seven
people in the Democratic primary now it
is a two-man race between Bernie Sanders
a Democratic Socialist and Joe Biden the
guy from The Naked Gun movies so boy
don't tell Biden that he's fallen and he
can't get up cuz this guy keeps coming
at you I mean you know you know that
he's been running for president since
1988 I'm serious 1988 1988 air-supply
was a band now it's what Joe needs when
he
gets to the top of the stairs okay but
the big story Bernie Bernie's young
voters did not show up the smell of
victory was Old Spice not Axe body spray
yeah
kids I guess kids are kids you know
after the polls close on Tuesday were
trending on Twitter was a hashtag oh
that was today
so there's talk I think this is crazy I
don't think it's gonna happen there is
talk that Bernie and Biden might team up
for a hundred and fifty six-year-old
ticket they already have the slogan four
more months
you